bonsoir anne sophie pelletier merci des
travaux merci beaucoup d'être avec nous
sur rt france les ehpad est ce que ce
sera elle a honte de cette crise je
prends les termes de votre livre
évidemment après le drame de la canicule
qui l'ont déjà subi le coronavirus aussi
ce sera quelque chose d'extrêmement à
dramatique pour eux les ehpad était déjà
une ronde française avant cette épidémie
est avec cette épidémie on ne fait que
surligner ce que déjà les soignants
criait c'est à dire le manque de moyens
cette épidémie aujourd'hui dans les
ehpad c'est un monstre qui rentre dans
des établissements pour personnes âgées
dépendantes et je crains que ce soit
pire que la canicule de 2003 et si vous
me permettez je ne voudrais pas penser
qu aux ehpad mais je voudrais prendre un
prisme un peu plus larges de la
vieillesse parce que la dépendance elle
commence au domicile et nous avons eu
aujourd'hui à nombre de décès à domicile
qui est de 9000 personnes dont on ne
parle pas dans les chiffres et je
voudrais penser aux auxiliaires de vie à
domicile
je voudrais penser aux aides à domicile
qui n'ont pas eu de protection pas de
masque pour aller s'occuper de leurs
bénéficiaires ça s'appelle comme ça j'ai
fait ce métier et qui aujourd'hui porte
la culpabilité à la fois de pouvoir être
vecteur d'un virus qui on le sait touche
particulièrement les personnes âgées est
à la fois et bien on leur a demandé de
prendre des risques dès finalement de
faire des choix impossibles
autant pour les soignants tous les
personnels des ehpad est en fait tous
les personnels qui s'occupe des
personnes les plus fragiles vous parlez
d'un chiffre de 9000 personnes décédées
à domicile cela concerne les personnes
âgées ou ont toutes les personnes qui
sont décédées à domicile nous n'avons
pas pour l'instant de catégorisation
mais par exemple dans mon département le
jura on est à + 26 % de morts à domicile
particulièrement sur les personnes âgées
dans le contexte on est à plus de 160 8
% de taux de mortalité on voit bien que
ce virus s'attaque évidemment aux plus
fragiles et je voudrais aussi la passer
un message
ont perdu un médecin urgentiste à lons
le saunier dans le jura médecin
urgentiste qui s'est battu pour que la
santé soit un bien commun et qui est
décédé du convive 19 pensent qu'il
n'avait pas été assez protégé donc
malheureusement je pense que nous ne
pourrons faire les comptes
c'est terrible à dire mais que quand
cette pandémie sera terminée avec les
études démographiques par exemple là je
pense que la polémique n'est pas de mise
il faut surtout penser à sauver le plus
de monde possible dont les personnes
âgées
le fait d'avoir pu rouvrir les ehpad aux
proches pour autoriser les visites à ces
personnes c'est important c'était une
chose essentielle pour eux oui c'était
une chose essentielle parce que il y à
des personnes âgées qui ne décideront
pas du coup vite dans les ehpad et
heureusement mais on le voit ce
confinement est difficile surtout quand
vous avez des troubles cognitifs et nos
personnes âgées dans les ehpad et des
remontées que nous avons à et bien c'est
un isolement psychologique qui induit un
glissement finalement un glissement dans
la pathologie et un haut personnage et
un sourire d'un proche
c'est important et ça évitera en tout
cas c'est tout le monde est bien protégé
c'est tout le monde est bien protégé à
ce qu'il y ait ces glissements dans les
ehpad les aînés ce sont les grands
oubliés de cette crise selon vous on l'a
dit parfois l'âge était un critère de
sélection notamment dans les hôpitaux
oui mais les aînés c'est ça fait pas
depuis la pandémie qu'on se rend compte
que ce sont les grands oubliés
vous avez certainement déjà passé des
reportages sur la catastrophe dans les
ehpad est le manque de moyens les aînés
ont toujours été les grands oubliés mais
pas que les aînés les personnes en
situation de handicap aussi donc encore
une fois on se rend compte parce que
nous avons fait un référé au niveau du
conseil d'état avec la cgt santé et fo
santé
nous avons fait un référé pour demander
des comptes au gouvernement nous avons
été déboutés de toutes nos demandes
c'est à dire les test systématique et
régulier ainsi que les masques et les
livraisons de masques dans les ehpad
toutes nos demandes ont été rejetées
on voit bien encore que nos aînés ne
sont pas la priorité de nos gouvernants
et là c'est tout c'est toute une
génération qui est en train de partir
et peut-être sur n'aura le temps on
parlera aussi pour les familles parce
que je ne veux pas les oublier mais pour
les familles qui ne peuvent voir leurs
proches décédés parce qu'il y a les
rites funéraires qui sont complètement
arrêtée depuis cette pandémie
et bien moi je voudrais aussi penser aux
familles parce que je ne sais pas
comment ils vont faire leur deuil
comment ils vont réussir à faire leur
deuil la loi sur le grand âge est
essentiel plus que jamais dans ce
contexte il faudra tirer les leçons en
tout cas et revoir complètement à la
politique les concernant mais ça fait
des années que nous le dise on y lit un
très bon rapport circonstancié de ma
collègue caroline fiat qui déjà demandé
à ce que des ratios personnel résidents
soit augmentée nous avons vu des grandes
grèves en 2018 comme le 31 janvier et le
15 mars où les personnels soignants
demandait plus de moyens et puis vous
m'excuserez je vais être très radical
mais à un moment donné j'espère que nous
tirons des leçons de l'histoire est que
plus jamais il n'y aura des pâtes privé
à but lucratif
oui c'est la logique arrivants qui
finalement marchandises la vieillesse la
logique est pas une marchandise
effectivement la logique de rentabilité
de certains de ces établissements on a
fait des reportages ici sur rt france
sur cette question
donc il va falloir revoir peut-être un
autre modèle pour la prise en charge de
ses aînés les réinsérer dans dans toutes
les catégories socioprofessionnelles et
quelles que soient les âges peut-être la
difficulté c'est que quand les personnes
âgées sont en ehpad
ça veut dire qu'elles sont dépendantes
et qu'elles n'ont plus la possibilité de
racheter c'est de rester chez elle donc
ce n'est pas une raison pour leur
enlever leur citoyenneté parce que quand
une personne âgée par passent les portes
d'un ehpad l etat visibiliser les
soignants sont invisibilité le personnel
et invisibilité
et revoir une politique du grand âge sir
de la solidarité
je pense que nous leur devons nous leur
devons parce que nous avons encore des
personnes âgées qui ont fait la guerre
qui ont qui se sont battus pour que nous
ayons des conflits sociaux que emmanuel
macron est en train de détruire petit à
petit mais cette solidarité nationale
elle est à mon sens juste du bon sens
parce que nous leur devons beaucoup
vous savez chez des personnes âgées
c'est un choix de métier le travail avec
des personnes âgées et c'est un choix de
métier parce que jamais vous
n'apprendrez dans les livres d'histoire
ce que eux sont capables de vous
raconter jamais et nous leur devons
cette reconnaissance cette
reconnaissance d'avoir ce que nous avons
aujourd'hui donc la politique du grand
âge pour qu'elle soit plus juste et bien
c'est déjà de remettre la vieillesse
dans le giron du public plus des pas de
priver et c'est aussi plus non plus
parce qu'on parle de la fin de vie de la
fin de vie pardon mais c'est aussi
remettre la mort dans le giron du public
parce qu'il est inconcevable que selon
vos moyens vous ayez les possibilités ou
pas dans ternes et d'enterrer pardon je
suis arrivé excusez moi j'ai la reprise
mais d'enterrer vos proches dignement ou
pas remettons tout s'est tu
tout ce pan de la société dans le giron
du public et soyons solidaires de nos
anciens de nos aînés de nos sages qui
nous apporte beaucoup qui nous
apprennent beaucoup et qui eux ont tiré
des lits sont des leçons de l'histoire
qui sont finalement le bon sens juste le
bon sens vous parliez de ces familles
qui ont perdu un proche dans cette crise
le fait de pouvoir faire son deuil
dignement n'est n'est pas possible vu
les circonstances avec le déconfinement
le 11 mai est ce que les choses
pourraient s'améliorer
je ne sais pas vous savez parce que les
protocoles funéraires sont très
particulier avec cette crise du que
vides les personnes âgées qui décède en
ehpad sont mises
excusez moi ça va être un peu dur mais
sont mis dans des housses mortuaires et
souvent les familles n'ont pas
accès à leurs proches ne peuvent pas
aller voir une dernière fois donc
j'espère en tout cas que avec ces
nouvelles mesures qui sont prises et
bien les familles pourront commencer la
première étape de deuil mais c'est
tellement violent tellement violent pour
les familles parce que je veux le
rappeler les familles ne place pas leurs
personnages et dans les ehpad par
plaisir elles le font parce qu'elles
n'ont pas le choix elles n'ont pas le
choix et elle espère que leurs
personnages et leurs proches leurs
parents seront pris en soins dans toute
la dignité qui leur est dû et ce n'est
pas le cas ça fait des années que ce
n'est pas le cas donc avec ces nouvelles
mesures
peut-être probablement ça aidera les
familles mais en tout cas j'ai bien peur
qu après cette crise sanitaire cette
pandémie
ces chocs terribles eh bien on est des
familles qu'ils soient dans une
souffrance incommensurable et j'ai bien
peur que les soignants qui travaillent
en ehpad
et bien soit soir avec le regard d'une
personne âgée qui est en train de
décider parce qu'on ne l'a pas pris à
l'hôpital et que cela augmente en tout
cas les risques psychosociaux de ces
femmes et ces hommes qui ont été envoyés
en première ligne sans protection et on
en parlera bien évidemment de ce suivi
de ces personnes évidemment qui ont été
face à des situations traumatisantes
merci beaucoup à mme sophie pelletier
d'avoir répondu à nos questions sur rt
france